Brian and also you've been all is at the  end of your publicity tour oh thank god  yeah got a couple of cities to go oh  you're still okay right  I'm very having I've been having a great  time on this press to him yeah his ryan  attracts a lot of young women but he's  in a committed relationship so you know  need a shoulder to cry father figure  just glad Jody's here honestly we get a  little feminine energy up in this  situation it's been my job to provide  that and I don't you know I've been  doing my best but the well only go so  deep we go to therapy we've had it's  been a long run we're doing all right  now aren't we pal can I touch you  sorry Russell doesn't like direct eye  contact he takes it as a sign of  aggression I know you episode of Graham  Thursdays at 11:30 yokota full episodes  available on BBC America del Carmen on  demand